Rachel was identity thefted. And at first, it was the kind of thing that you hear about. Money was vanishing from her bank account, and it turned out to be some charges and ATM withdrawals that she hadn't made herself. So she found this out, but she figured, OK, no problem. Call the bank, explain the situation. They'll take care of it. She even figured out how it probably happened. She had been visiting friends in Chicago, sitting in a coffee shop.
雷切尔遭遇了身份盗用。起初，这只是那种你在别处听到的事情。她银行账户里的钱开始消失，后来发现是一些她本人并未进行的扣款和自动提款。她发现了这一点，但心想，没问题，给银行打电话说明情况，他们会处理好的。她甚至想通了这事是怎么发生的——当时她在芝加哥探望朋友，坐在一家咖啡馆里。
And this guy walked in wearing a windbreaker and sat at the table next to us. And at one point, he just brushed against me, and I had my purse actually hanging over the chair. And it wasn't until after he had left and I went to pay that I realized that my wallet was gone.
有个穿着防风衣的男人走进来，坐在我们旁边的桌子旁。有一次，他从我身边擦过，我的钱包当时正挂在椅子上。直到他离开，我去结账时才发现钱包不见了。
But you just figured that was the person who stole your identity?
但你就认定那是偷你身份的人吗？
Yeah. My social security card had been in there, and I thought that was something you could do without.
是的。我的社保卡就在里面，我以为那种东西丢了也没什么大不了的。
So she goes and closes out her bank account, switches to a different bank. Same thing happens. Money just starts disappearing. And she goes through several banks this way. It was like a game of bank-a-mole. Wherever her money goes, the identity thief arrives.
于是她去注销了银行账户，换了一家银行。同样的事情又发生了。钱又开始莫名消失。她就这样换了好几家银行，就像在玩“打地鼠”游戏一样。无论她的钱转到哪里，身份窃贼就会如影随形。
I was like, I don't really know what else I can do. I closed everything.
我当时想，我真的不知道还能做什么。我把一切都注销了。
It really started to freak her out, for money to just keep vanishing, inexplicably, out of her control.
钱在无法解释的情况下不断消失，超出了她的控制范围，这让她真的感到恐慌。
I started to become just a very paranoid person all the time. After this had been happening for a year or two, I was just very anxious all the time. There was one point where I thought that my mail was being stolen because I was like, how else is this happening? So I got a PO box, and I got to the point where I thought someone was following me. I was just so paranoid that I would try to find alternate routes to get to my PO box so that--
我开始变得整天疑神疑鬼。这种情况持续了一两年后，我一直感到非常焦虑。有一次，我甚至怀疑是我的信件被人偷了，因为我想，不然怎么会这样？所以我去租了一个邮政信箱，到后来我甚至觉得有人在跟踪我。我变得极其多疑，以至于总是试图找些绕道的路线去我的邮政信箱，这样……
They couldn't figure out where your PO box is and hack your PO box?
他们就找不到你的邮政信箱，也就没法黑进你的信箱了？
Yeah. I mean, it sounds so crazy, looking back. To be honest, I didn't have that much money. I was working at a non-profit children's museum and trying to wait tables to supplement my income. But my boyfriend at the time was helping me out. I always paid my rent. I didn't want him to pay for me or anything. It was very uncomfortable for me, but he would buy the groceries and do everything. I would pay my rent, and he would take care of everything else.
是啊。现在回想起来，这听起来真是太疯狂了。老实说，我并没有那么多钱。当时我在一家非营利性儿童博物馆工作，为了增加收入还去餐馆做兼职。但当时的男朋友一直在帮我。我总是自己付房租，我不希望他为我出钱什么的。这让我感觉很不自在，但他会买杂货，处理一切。我只负责房租，其他的事情都由他打理。
And what did he do for a living?
那他是做什么工作的？
So he was always into politics. So at that point, he was working at the Massachusetts State House, working for the president of the Senate.
他一直对政治很感兴趣。当时他在马萨诸塞州议会工作，为参议院议长效力。
Oh. Fancy.
哦，高级。
Yeah, fancy job.
是啊，高级工作。
And without him, she'd really be sunk, because money just keeps vanishing from her bank accounts. So eventually, she just gives up on the entire banking system. She closes her last account, has the bank put all of the money that was remaining, $1,000, into a bank check that she keeps in a drawer, handles all of her finances in cash and money orders. Problem solved at last.
没有他，她就彻底完了，因为钱一直在从她的账户里消失。最终，她对整个银行系统彻底放弃了。她注销了最后一个账户，让银行把剩下的1000美元全部提现存入一张银行支票，放在抽屉里，所有的财务往来都用现金和汇票解决。问题总算解决了。
Until she and her boyfriend decide they're going to move and she needs the $1,000. And she goes to the top dresser drawer, where she keeps all of her financial stuff, the receipts and statements and all of that, and there's no check. And she's like, OK, well, maybe it fell behind the dresser. Maybe  I put it somewhere else.
直到她和男朋友决定搬家，她需要那1000美元。她走到存放所有财务资料、收据和对账单的梳妆台最上层抽屉里，却发现支票不见了。她心想，好吧，也许是掉在梳妆台后面了，也许是我放在别的地方了。
And so we tore apart the apartment, just flipping couch cushions and opening drawers. And I was just having a panic attack, because this was all of the money that I had in the world, and we couldn't find it.
于是我们把公寓翻了个底朝天，掀开沙发垫子，打开所有抽屉。我当时简直要恐慌发作了，因为那是我所有的积蓄，我们却找不到它。
So she goes to the bank. And they were like, you already cashed this check. And they showed her a copy.
于是她去了银行。银行告诉她，你已经兑现了这张支票。他们还给她看了一份复印件。
And then where my signature was was my forged signature, and it was my boyfriend's handwriting.
我签名的地方被伪造了，那是男朋友的笔迹。
Bum-bum-bum. It was the boyfriend. After all, think about it. Who else could it be? In retrospect, Rachel says that she is sure there was some small part of her in the back of her brain which was like, OK, what if it's him?
咚咚咚。原来是男朋友干的。毕竟，仔细想想，还能是谁呢？回想起来，雷切尔说她确信自己大脑深处有一个小小的念头，在想：好吧，万一是他呢？
I mean, of course it's something you would think about, and the banks are always like, do you have a boyfriend? It's the boyfriend.
我的意思是，这当然是你自然会想到的，而且银行总是问：“你有男朋友吗？”肯定是男朋友干的。
The banks would say that? They would suggest that?
银行会这么说？他们会暗示这一点吗？
Yeah. Any bank or police officer would always be like, do you have a boyfriend? It's the boyfriend. It's always the boyfriend. And I was like, you don't know my boyfriend.
是的。任何银行人员或警察总是会问：“你有男朋友吗？”肯定是男朋友。总是男朋友。而我当时说：“你们根本不了解我的男朋友。”
"You don't know my boyfriend." These are like magic words that sometimes keep people from seeing things that are right in front of their face.
“你们不了解我的男朋友。”这些话就像咒语，有时让人看不见就在眼皮子底下的真相。
You don't know my boyfriend. My boyfriend is, like, the king of generosity and kindness, just so giving all the time to everyone, just giving. He just wanted to give.
“你们不了解我的男朋友。我男朋友是慷慨和善良之王，他总是对每个人都那么大方，一直在给予。他只是想给予。”
You don't know my boyfriend. You don't know my wife. You don't know my spouse. You don't know my partner. You don't know them like I know them. This is one of the dangers of getting close to somebody. To get close, you have to agree, I trust you, I believe you, I know that what you say is true, you know what I say is true. And sometimes that is a mistake. That's one of the perils of intimacy.
“你不了解我的男朋友。你不了解我的妻子。你不了解我的配偶。你不了解我的伴侣。你不了解他们，像我了解他们那样。”这是与人亲近的危险之一。要亲近，你就必须达成共识：我信任你，我相信你，我知道你说的是真的，你知道我说的是真的。但有时这是一种错误。这是亲密带来的风险之一。
There are others too, of course. That's what our show's about today, the perils of intimacy. Today, we have grown men awkwardly trying to make friends with each other not sure what to talk about. We have people on nervous first dates, bravely fighting their own insecurities and anxieties. There are downsides to being close to somebody. Let's talk about that for a change, instead of how great it is to be married forever and blah, blah, blah, Bridget Jones' wedding toast, blah, blah, blah.
当然还有其他风险。这就是我们今天节目讨论的主题：亲密的代价。今天，有成年男性尴尬地试图建立友谊，却不知道该聊些什么；有在紧张的第一次约会上，勇敢对抗内心不安全感和焦虑的人们。与人亲近是有代价的。让我们换个话题聊聊这个，而不是整天谈论那些永远幸福美满的童话，或者布里奇特·琼斯的婚礼祝酒词那一套。
Single people, there are 32 million of you living alone, 107 million of you unmarried. Here is an hour to make you feel good about that for a change. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, losers.
各位单身人士，你们有3200万人独自生活，1.07亿人未婚。这里有一个小时的时间，让你们换个心情，对自己当下的状态感觉好一点。来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。留下来吧，失败者们。
So when Rachel came back from the bank from seeing her boyfriend's handwriting on the check that he stole from her, when she got back to the studio apartment that they shared to confront him with the truth, obviously, how was she not going to ditch him? But he sat on the bed with her and did something. He broke down crying. And he said, I have to tell you something.
当雷切尔从银行回来，看到支票上那行窃者留下的她男朋友的笔迹时，当她回到他们合租的公寓要与他对质真相时，按理说，她怎么能不甩了他呢？但他坐在床边，做了一件事。他崩溃大哭，说：“我必须告诉你一件事。”
And I don't want to tell you, because I'm afraid that if I tell you, you're going to leave me. And that's when he told me that he has impulse control disorder, that he's been diagnosed with this for many years, and that he's done a lot of stupid stuff. And he said he was seeing a therapist and getting help for it.
“我不想告诉你，因为我怕如果我说了，你会离开我。”就在那时，他告诉我他患有冲动控制障碍，多年来一直被诊断出有这个问题，他做过很多愚蠢的事情。他说他在看心理医生，并在寻求帮助。
How long had you guys been together?
你们在一起多久了？
Probably four years, three years.
大概四三年吧，三四年左右。
Yeah. I don't want to be disrespectful to somebody's actual disease, but the name impulse control disorder just sounds like the name of-- well, that's just saying, well, I just couldn't help myself.
是啊。我不想对别人的真实疾病表现出不尊重，但“冲动控制障碍”这个名字听起来就像……那简直是在说：“好吧，我就是控制不住自己。”
Totally.
完全同意。
I just wanted to take money from a cash register. I have impulse control disorder.
“我就是想从收银台偷钱。我有冲动控制障碍。”
Right.
没错。
I just wanted to sleep with your sister. I have impulse control disorder.
“我就是想跟你姐姐上床。我有冲动控制障碍。”
Right.
没错。
It just seems like the most-- I mean, I say with respect to people who might have this as a real disorder.
这看起来实在是……我的意思是，我尊重那些可能确实患有这种病的人。
Right. And you know when you tell these stories and then you just feel like, how do you not know? You just sound so stupid. But back then, I think I needed to hear that there was some sort of medical reason. OK, it's not--
对，你知道，当你讲述这些故事时，你会觉得自己怎么会那么迟钝？听起来真的很愚蠢。但在当时，我想我需要听到有一个医学上的理由。好吧，这不是……
At least it was an explanation.
至少这是一个解释。
Yeah. Like, he's not a bad person. He's just going through something that's out of his control and it's medical.
对，就像，他不是个坏人。他只是在经历某些他无法控制的医学问题。
Yeah, it's interesting how a person would want that rather than the other thing.
是的，一个人宁愿要那个解释，而不是其他真相，这很有趣。
Well, yeah-- like a bow I could tie up and here's why. Not like, you've been living for years with a sociopath. The other one sounded better.
嗯，是的，就像一个我能系上的蝴蝶结，解释了原因。而不是说，“你已经和一个反社会者生活了多年”。前者听起来好多了。
So at the time she accepted, all right, he has an impulse control disorder. And she believed that the disorder is what caused him to steal the very last money she had in this world and forge her name on a check and then search for the check with her, pretending he had no idea where the check could have gone. But that's all she thought he did. That tiny morsel of truth was all she was able to take in at that point.
所以在当时她接受了，好吧，他患有冲动控制障碍。她相信是这种障碍导致他偷走了她世上最后的钱，伪造了她的名字签在支票上，然后还陪着她到处找支票，假装自己不知道支票去哪儿了。但她认为他只做了这些。在那一刻，那一丁点的真相是她唯一能承受的东西。
She did not put together the whole truth, that he'd been stealing from her for over a year, that he was the identity thief, not some stranger in a dingy apartment in Chicago. He was the identity thief who made her so totally stressed out over money all the time, who drove her to the point where she was looking over her shoulder as she walked to her own post office box.
她没有拼凑出完整的真相：他已经偷了她一年多了，他才是那个身份窃贼，而不是芝加哥那间破旧公寓里的某个陌生人。他就是那个让她因为钱的问题一直感到压力巨大、逼得她走去邮政信箱时都要提心吊胆的那个“身份窃贼”。
They stayed together for another year and a half. And before you judge, before you think how could she do that, I'll explain how. It's really interesting, and I think it could happen to a lot of us. For starters, her boyfriend had been the one steady thing in her life, right? She's going through this hard time with banks and credit cards, and it's not ending. And he was the one thing she thought she could depend on. It was just hard to let that go.
他们又在一起待了一年半。在评判她之前，在你觉得她怎么能那样做之前，我会解释原因。这真的很有趣，我认为这可能会发生在很多我们身上。首先，她男朋友一直是她生活中唯一稳定的东西，对吧？她经历了银行和信用卡的那些烂摊子，而且没完没了，而他是她唯一觉得可以依靠的人。要放弃这一点很难。
Ugh, God, it makes me sound so stupid. But yeah, I really thought I knew what good was. Everything felt so bad and so hard to control, I was like, he has to be good. Because if he's not good, nothing is good.
天哪，这让我听起来真蠢。但确实，我当时真以为我知道什么是“好”。一切都感觉那么糟糕，那么难以掌控，所以我当时想：他一定是好的。因为如果他不好，那一切就都没希望了。
Right. That's the whole premise. That's the premise of your life.
对，这就是前提。这是你生活的前提。
Right. Yeah. I was like, rationally, there's no way that it was him because he literally supports me. He buys all of our groceries, and he pays all of our bills, and he is legitimately my personal army to try and figure out the identity fraud.
没错。是的。我当时觉得，从理性上讲，他绝不可能是那个窃贼，因为他实际上在支持我。他买所有的杂货，付所有的账单，他简直是我对抗身份欺诈的私人军队。
Right. So it just doesn't add up. How could that person be taking money from me, the person who's actually paying for everything?
对，所以这根本说不通。那个实际上在支付一切开销的人，怎么可能是那个偷走我钱的人？
Right. Yeah. So I was like, why would someone steal from you and then spend it on you? It just didn't make sense to me.
没错。所以我当时心想，为什么有人会偷你的钱，然后又把它花在你的身上？这对我来说根本讲不通。
But weird financial stuff keeps happening. Rachel gets phone calls about credit cards that are in her name that she never took out and knew nothing about. Her car gets booted, even though Rachel never got a ticket herself. And occasionally, the thought would cross her mind, OK, if I broke up with him, would all those troubles go away? And she would just brush that thought away. Once, the boyfriend's stepmother said something to Rachel.
但奇怪的财务状况不断出现。雷切尔接到电话，说有名下信用卡她从没办过也一无所知。她的车被锁了，尽管雷切尔自己从没违章过。偶尔，一个念头会闪过她的脑海：好吧，如果我跟他分手，所有这些麻烦会消失吗？她会把这个念头赶走。有一次，男朋友的继母对雷切尔说了些话。
She was like the evil stepmom that he-- he hated her. And he kind of got me to hate her. And I realized years later, she was the only one who was onto him.
她就像他口中的邪恶继母，他很恨她，他也搞得我也跟着恨她。几年后我才意识到，她是唯一看穿他的人。
This happened early on. The stepmom said to Rachel, I hear you're having some kind of identity theft problems.
这发生得较早。继母对雷切尔说：“我听说你们遇到了一些身份盗用的麻烦。”
I was like, yeah. And she was like, do you guys go over bills together? Do you guys ever do that kind of stuff together? And I was like, no, I don't want to do it. It stresses me out. And she was like, a really important part of a relationship is figuring out financial stuff. Maybe you should look into that and make sure that he's got things under control-- you know, really tried to get me to do stuff with him.
我说：“是的。”她说：“你们一起核对过账单吗？你们会一起处理这类事情吗？”我说：“不，我不想做，这让我压力很大。”她说：“一段关系中很重要的一部分就是一起理清财务。也许你应该查查，确保他把事情处理好了……”你知道，她真的试图让我和他一起做这些事。
And I honestly-- I know she said something rude about him, like, he's not great at this. And I shut it down. I was just like, you don't know. Because he made me hate her. So years later, I realized, oh my God, she tried to warn me. But he had done such a good job of protection that I was like, she's not even a candidate for trusting.
老实说，我知道她说了一些关于他很粗鲁的话，比如他在这方面不擅长。我就打断了她，说：“你不了解他。”因为他让我恨她。所以几年后我意识到，天哪，她是想警告我。但他之前做了很好的自我保护工作，以至于我当时想，她连被信任的资格都没有。
It's interesting to think about, what was in this for the boyfriend? You know what I mean? Stealing from her, making her feel so anxious or paranoid about her finances, and then stepping in to comfort her and save the day and help her out, using her money.
考虑到这一点很有趣，男朋友从中得到了什么？我的意思是，从她身上偷钱，让她为财务感到焦虑或多疑，然后介入去安慰她，扮演救世主，帮她解决问题，用的还是她的钱。
He was like a caretaker. It made him really happy. He really wanted to provide. I think he really wanted to be a provider. And he would make me these fancy dinners every night and pack my lunch for work and stuff like that.
他就像个照顾者。这让他非常快乐。他真的很想提供帮助。我想他真的很想做一个供养者。他每天晚上都会为我做精美的晚餐，为我准备午餐带去工作，诸如此类。
So like I say, a year and a half passes, and he asks Rachel to marry him. She says yes. She's really happy. The next morning-- this happens the very next morning-- she gets a call from their landlord, who the boyfriend had always dealt with.
所以正如我所说，一年半过去了，他向雷切尔求婚。她答应了。她真的很高兴。第二天早上，就在第二天一早，她接到了房东的电话，房东之前一直是由男朋友联系的。
And he was just screaming. He's like, I don't know what you and your boyfriend are trying to pull, but you owe me $16,000, whatever it was. And you're being evicted. And why aren't you returning my calls? And I was like, I have no idea what you're talking about. And he was like, you're a liar, just like your boyfriend.
他在电话里大吼大叫。他说：“我不知道你和你男朋友想干什么，但你欠了我1.6万美元，无论具体是多少。你们被驱逐了。为什么不回我的电话？”我当时说：“我不知道你在说什么。”他说：“你是个骗子，和你男朋友一样。”
She'd been giving her boyfriend her half of the rent, but he hadn't paid the landlord in a year. And she was like, OK, well, where did that money go? And she started to look for it. She went through his stuff for the first time without him around and opened drawers and found all kinds of bills and credit cards in his name from American Express and Banana Republic and all kinds of other places, a whole secret financial chaos. And then they fight about how he'd been lying to her.
她一直把那份房租交给男朋友，但他一年没付给房东。她想，好吧，那钱去哪儿了？她开始寻找。她第一次在他不在的时候翻了他的东西，打开抽屉，发现了各种以他名义办的信用卡账单，有美国运通的，有Banana Republic的，还有其他各种地方的——一个完全隐秘的财务黑洞。然后他们为他一直对她撒谎这件事吵了起来。
And this is what breaks them up, though it takes a few weeks for them to break up-- which I get. He'd been her college boyfriend. They'd been together five years. They were engaged. So, OK, it takes weeks. And during those weeks, horribly--
这就是导致他们分手的导火索，尽管他们花了几个星期才真正分开——这我理解。他是她的大学恋人，他们在一起五年了，已经订婚。所以，好吧，这需要时间。在这些周里，可怕的是——
We started planning a wedding. Like, I kind of went into a catatonic state of existence, where I went through the motions for a month, where we would go look at wedding places. But in the back of my mind, it was like, I can't marry this person. But I couldn't say it out loud.
我们开始筹划婚礼。我就像进入了一种植物人状态，一个月里就像例行公事一样，去实地考察婚礼场地。但内心深处，我知道我不可能嫁给这个人。但我无法说出口。
I did call her boyfriend to run all this by him, everything Rachel said, and give him a chance to respond, but he said no. People close to Rachel and to him did confirm her story. So finally, they agreed they were going to take a break for a few days, think about things, talk to their families, and then come back and figure things out together.
我确实联系了她的男朋友，向他说明了雷切尔所说的一切，并给了他回应的机会，但他拒绝了。雷切尔和他的亲友证实了她的说法。最终，他们同意先分开几天，冷静思考，与家人商量，然后再回来共同解决问题。
And he went home to his parents, and I went to my parents. And I never, ever saw him ever again. Never.
他回到了他父母家，我回到了我父母家。我再也没见过他。再也没见过。
Months later, I was living with roommates and put together that for years I had been living with this person who was stealing from me, and started to put together, oh my god, he wasn't working. He would get up every day and get dressed and leave the house when I left the house, and he would pretend to go to work. I never went to his office.
几个月后，我和室友住在一起，回想起多年来我一直和这个一直在偷我钱的人住在一起。我开始意识到，天哪，他根本没有工作。他每天起床穿好衣服，在我出门的时候离开家，假装去上班。我从没去过他的办公室。
When he was working at the State House, he showed me his office from the car. He was like, look, that gold domed building, that's where I work. I'm so excited. And I just realized, I don't know anything that was real. I don't know when he was working or when he wasn't.
当他在议会大厦工作时，他在车里指给我看过他的办公室。他说：“看，那个金顶建筑就是我工作的地方。我太激动了。”我才意识到，我根本不知道什么是真实的。我不知道他什么时候在工作，什么时候不在。
You never met any of his office-mates?
你从没见过他的办公室同事？
No. I heard stories about them all the time.
没有。但我总是听到关于他们的故事。
Oh. So he had names of people who he said he worked with?
哦。所以他给那些他说一起工作的同事编了名字？
Totally.
完全是这样。
What were their names?
他们叫什么名字？
Well, I remember Ann from the State House. He had a boss. I think he had named him Rob. And I just remember because there was this one time he called me at work. And he was really upset because he was at the airport. And he was like, we're all supposed to go on a trip to DC. And it ends up there's a problem with the flight and we have to get put on the next flight, and there's not enough room for everyone. And I'm really bummed because I don't think I'm going to get to go on the trip. Because I'm not important enough. I'm not high up enough.
嗯，我记得议会大厦的安。他有个老板，我想他叫罗伯。我记得特别清楚，因为有一次他在我工作时给我打电话。他非常沮丧，因为他在机场。他说：“我们都要去华盛顿出差。结果航班出了问题，我们需要换乘下一班，但位子不够。我很沮丧，因为我觉得我没法去了，因为我不够重要，职位不够高。”
And he ended up not being able to go on the trip. And he was calling me from the airport telling me this story. And I felt so bad for him. But he didn't work, and those people weren't real, and he wasn't at the airport. I don't know. He was probably at home.
最后他没去成。他从机场打电话给我编了这个故事。我当时为他感到难过。但其实他根本没工作，那些人也不是真的，他也不在机场。我不知道，他可能在家里。
We have this idea that when we discover the truth it hits us all at once. You know, we see what's real and what isn't in a flash of understanding. In fact, the thing that we call an experience like that is "the moment of truth." That's what we say, "the moment of truth." We do not say "the dragged out year and a half of the truth."
我们有一种观念：真相一经发现就会瞬间击中我们。你知道，我们会在顿悟的闪光中看到什么是真实，什么是虚假。事实上，我们将那种经历称为“真相时刻”。我们说的是“真相时刻”，而不是“漫长的一年半真相揭露过程”。
But that's how it goes sometimes. Sometimes we come to accept the truth slowly, in stages. Sometimes we have reasons to hold on to a lie. We're not ready to let go of the world that the lie preserves, the people the lie keeps close to us. And we release the lie from our hand one finger at a time.
但事情有时就是这样。有时我们缓慢地接受真相，分阶段地接受。有时我们有理由抓住一个谎言不放。我们还没准备好放弃谎言所维系的那个世界，放弃谎言让我们保持亲近的那些人。于是我们一根手指一根手指地松开，从手中释放那个谎言。
Act Two, "Why Can't We Be Friends?" OK, fellow adults. Here's a question. When did you last make a friend? I mean an actual friend who you see regularly, you talk about actual personal things. It's hard, right, to make a new one? To get to that point? To get through the awkward, "hey, you want to hang out sometime" phase?
第二幕，“为什么我们不能做朋友？”好的，各位成年人。有个问题：你上次交朋友是什么时候？我是指那种经常见面、聊个人私事的真正的朋友。很难吧，对吧？结识新朋友，达到那种程度，度过那个尴尬的“嘿，你想什么时候出来玩吗”的阶段。
I'm in this thing right now with this guy who honestly I thought maybe we were going to become friends. And he sent me an email saying, hey, let's have dinner. And I thought, great. And I responded with a specific time. I said, Thursday, how about Thursday? Heard nothing.
我现在就遇到这种情况，有一个人，老实说，我曾以为我们能成为朋友。他发邮件说：“嘿，一起吃顿晚餐吧。”我觉得太好了，于是回复了一个具体时间。我说：“周四，这周四怎么样？”结果毫无回应。
Then, a few days later, in an email about something completely else, he suggested again, hey, we should do dinner sometime. And again I was like, great. How about Thursday? Again, heard nothing.
然后，几天后，在聊另一件完全不相干的事情时，他又建议道：“嘿，我们得找个时间吃顿晚餐。”我再次回应说：“太好了。周四怎么样？”结果依然毫无回应。
What is that, people? How do adults become friends? Neil Drumming on our staff has run a little experiment with human Guinea pigs on this particular subject.
这是怎么回事？成年人到底怎么交朋友？我们组的尼尔·德鲁明针对这个话题进行了一项小型人类实验。
I have no idea how adults make new friends. I'd like to, but I'm not really trying. I don't join clubs. I don't ask my co-workers out for drinks. And when I am at bars, I don't do this.
我完全不知道成年人如何交新朋友。我想交，但其实并没怎么尝试。我不参加俱乐部，不叫同事出来喝酒。当我在酒吧时，我也不会这样做。
I have gone out by myself, just trying to talk about sports, what is usually what's blaring on the TV, or about the beer. Like, I'll notice someone just ordered a beer next to me. I'm like, oh, how is that? I really like hoppy beers. Blah, blah, blah.
我一个人出去过，试着聊聊体育，聊聊电视里大声播着的东西，或者聊啤酒。比如，我会注意到旁边的人点了一杯啤酒，我说：“哦，这酒怎么样？我真的很喜欢这种啤酒花味重的。”诸如此类。
That's Chris Gerben, poor guy. He's 37 years old. Nine months ago, he moved his family from San Francisco to Austin for a teaching gig at a small university, leaving most of his male friends back on the West Coast. He has no choice but to start over. I haven't left New York in 16 years, but so many of my male friends have recently moved or drifted away that I probably need to start over too. I haven't done anything about it, except maybe complain and overburden my romantic relationships.
那是克里斯·格本，可怜的家伙。他37岁。九个月前，他为了在一所小型大学任教，把全家从旧金山搬到了奥斯汀，留下了他在西海岸的大部分男性朋友。他别无选择，只能重新开始。我16年没离开过纽约了，但我的许多男性朋友最近都搬走了或渐行渐远，以至于我也许需要重新开始。我除了抱怨和过度依赖我的浪漫关系外，什么都没做。
The thing I found remarkable about Chris was that he was being proactive. He was actively seeking male friends. He got on meetup.com. He formed a men's only book club. He memorized baseball statistics as conversation starters. He started going to bars expressly for the purpose of meeting other hetero dudes.
关于克里斯，让我觉得了不起的是他一直在主动出击。他积极寻找男性朋友。他上了Meetup网站，组建了一个只有男性的读书俱乐部。他背诵棒球统计数据作为对话素材。他去酒吧专门就是为了结识其他异性恋男性。
The only time I remember it ever going really well-- really well-- I'd been in Austin maybe for about a month. And I was sitting at this brewery near my house, and I was eating dinner. I think my wife had our daughter out somewhere. So I was on my own, and this guy sat next to me. And he was there with some of his friends.
我记得唯一一次进行得非常好的——真的很好——那时我搬到奥斯汀大概一个月。我坐在离家很近的一家啤酒厂吃晚饭。我想我妻子带着女儿出去了。所以我是一个人，这个家伙坐在我旁边。他和他的一些朋友在那儿。
And I don't even remember how it started, but at some point he actually turned towards me. And for a good, I would say, at least 20 minutes if not a half hour, it was just me and him. We were talking. And we were talking, talking, talking. I remember in the back of my head thinking, this is it. This is how you start a guy friendship.
我甚至不记得它是怎么开始的，但在某个点上，他真的转向了我。有至少20分钟，如果不是半小时的话，就只有我们两个。我们一直在聊，一直在聊，一直在聊。我记得脑海里心想，这就是了。这就是如何开始一段男性友谊。
And then, at some point he started talking about how he was a vet and he had been in Iraq. And he was talking about how he'd just flew somewhere. And he took his concealed gun into the airport, and the TSA flipped out about it.
然后，在某个点上，他开始谈论他是一名退伍军人，曾去过伊拉克。他说他刚飞了什么地方。他把隐蔽携带的枪带进了机场，结果TSA（运输安全管理局）对他大发雷霆。
And I'm thinking, OK. I'm not a gun guy, and I don't really even know anything about guns. But I'm just shaking my hand, like, OK, sure. I'm in Texas now. This is how it is.
我在想，好吧。我不是个玩枪的人，甚至对枪一无所知。但我只是摇着手说：“好的，当然。”我在得克萨斯州嘛，这儿就是这样。
And then, out of nowhere, I think he grabbed my knee, if I remember correctly. But he definitely moved closer to me and looked me right in the eye and said, you've got to get a gun, bro. You've got to protect your family. You've got to protect your daughter, bro. And I was like, oh yeah, I do.
然后，出人意料地，如果我没记错的话，他抓住了我的膝盖。但他绝对凑近了，直视我的眼睛说：“你得搞把枪，兄弟。你得保护你的家人。你得保护你的女儿，兄弟。”我当时说：“哦，是的，我确实需要。”
Wait. Did you feel like you needed a gun to protect your family?
等等。你当时真的觉得为了保护家人需要一把枪吗？
No, of course not!
不，当然不需要！
So why did you agree to continue along this line?
那你为什么还同意顺着他的话聊下去？
(CHUCKLING) Because I was desperate for friends.
（笑）因为我太渴望朋友了。
The only reason I know about Chris's predicament is because he emailed This American Life about it. And even though I could relate, I wouldn't have given the letter a second thought if it didn't remind me of my buddy, Evan. Evan, coincidentally, had also just moved to Austin with his partner and his young daughter. I could tell from Facebook that they'd managed to get set up OK, but Evan was already feeling lonely, that special kind of loneliness that people in long-term relationships often know too well.
之所以我知道克里斯的困境，是因为他发邮件给了《美国生活》。虽然我能感同身受，但如果这不是让我想起我的老友埃文，我可能根本不会多想。巧合的是，埃文也刚和他的伴侣及年幼的女儿搬到了奥斯汀。我从Facebook上看得出他们安顿得还行，但埃文已经感到了孤独——那种长期关系中的人通常非常熟悉的那种特殊的孤独。
We do things together. We're raising a child together, but we're not friends.
“我们一起做事情。我们在共同抚养孩子，但我们不是朋友。”
Yeah.
“是啊。”
You know?
“你知道吗？”
That's Evan. He's honest.
那是埃文。他很诚实。
The parts of my identity that make me who I am, being a nerd, reading and writing about comic books and video games and movies, I need somebody to share that with. Because we don't have similar interests in that regard, or similar tastes. So this is a part of me that I feel is important to me and I want somebody to care about and to share that with. And traditionally, that's where I've gone to my friends for.
“塑造我身份的那些部分——书呆子，阅读和撰写关于漫画书、电子游戏和电影的内容——我需要有人分享这些。因为我们在这方面没有相似的兴趣，或者相似的品味。这是我生命中我觉得重要的一部分，我希望有人关心并与之分享。传统上，我都是找朋友去做这些事的。”
Yeah.
“是啊。”
Evan is one of those friends I let slip away in a flurry of rain-checks earlier this year. We've known each other, I don't know, maybe 10 years now. He used to recommend comic books and Xbox games that I never read nor finished. Part of what I love about Evan is how unabashedly he is who he is. He's earnest, somewhat awkward, and above all, a nerd-- although I think he'd accept the term black geek. He says he wasn't always so confident about these parts of his personality. And moving to Austin, away from his friends and peers, living on the sleepy edge of town with only his partner and daughter, has put him in unfamiliar territory.
埃文是我今年因一连串借口推脱而渐渐疏远的朋友之一。我们认识得有……不知道，可能10年了吧。他曾经推荐过我从没读过或看完的漫画和Xbox游戏。我爱埃文的一部分原因在于他表现得如此坦率。他诚挚，有点笨拙，最重要的是，是个书呆子——尽管我认为他会接受“黑人极客”这个词。他说他以前对个性的这些方面并不那么自信。而搬到奥斯汀，远离了他的朋友和同侪，住在城镇寂静的边缘，只有伴侣和女儿相伴，让他处在陌生的领域。
What is your place like?
你的住处怎么样？
It's nice. There's a pool maybe a couple hundred feet away from us. And there's tennis courts, not that I'm ever going to use them. But it's nice.
很好。离我们大概几百英尺有个游泳池。还有网球场，虽然我永远不会去用它们。但住着很舒服。
Evan wasn't putting himself out there, but Chris was. And they live in the same city, both men, both dads, around the same age. Both want friends. Maybe I've been making it out to be harder than it actually is. Maybe all you have to do to make a friend is get off your ass and try. Here was a chance to find out without, you know, actually having to do anything myself. I'd fix Evan and Chris up on a date-- a man date.
埃文并没有主动出击，但克里斯做到了。他们住在同一个城市，都是男人，都是父亲，年纪相仿。都想要朋友。也许是我把它想得比实际情况更难了。也许交朋友所要做的只是站起来试一试。这是一个无需我自己做任何事就能找到答案的机会。我决定撮合埃文和克里斯去约会——一场男人约会。
You can't have a man date without an official activity. Those are the rules. So the first thing I did was write to Chris and Evan and ask them each what they were into. Chris sent me a list that included hiking, running, karaoke, and something called disc golf. Evan said he likes playing video games and eating-- oh, and drinking in moderation. I suggested they go sea Captain America: Civil War , which was coming out in a week. The trailer was awesome, plus the movie stars Chris Evans as Captain America. Chris Evans. That's fate, right?
没有正式活动就不能叫男人约会。这是规矩。所以我要做的第一件事是分别问问克里斯和埃文他们喜欢什么。克里斯发给我一份清单，包括徒步、跑步、卡拉OK，还有一种叫“圆盘高尔夫”的东西。埃文说他喜欢玩电子游戏和吃饭——哦，还有适度饮酒。我建议他们去看《美国队长3：内战》，电影一周后上映。预告片很赞，而且克里斯·埃文斯主演。克里斯·埃文斯。这就是天意，对吧？
The first thing I did was google him and see who this person was. I even went onto his Twitter feed and saw that he was interacting with people and retweeting people who seemed really big in his field. And it was intimidating. I mean, the first thing I thought was, I feel sorry for this guy having to go out with me. You know? I really felt like he didn't need this.
我要做的第一件事是谷歌搜索他，看看他是谁。我甚至上了他的Twitter，看到他正在与人互动，转发那些在他领域看来很有名的人。这很吓人。我的意思是，我第一个念头是：我为这个家伙不得不跟我出来约会感到抱歉。你知道吗？我真的觉得他不需要这个。
He felt like Evan was out of his league. Meanwhile, Evan was not even thinking about Chris. He never googled him. And when Chris gave Evan his phone number over email multiple times, Evan never responded with his. When I talked to Evan hours before the date, his biggest worry was traffic. He moved to Texas from New York City. He hadn't driven in years.
他觉得埃文高不可攀。与此同时，埃文根本没想过克里斯。他从没谷歌搜索过他。当克里斯多次通过邮件给埃文电话号码时，埃文从未回复过自己的。当我在约会前几个小时与埃文交谈时，他最大的担忧是交通。他从纽约搬到得克萨斯，好几年没开车了。
There's so much unpredictability surrounding you. Even when you feel like, I'm in control, I feel confident about my abilities, but you don't know who the [BLEEP] else is out there, making a sudden turn. It's stressful.
周围有太多的不可预测性。即使你觉得“我掌控得住，我对自己能力感到自信”，但你不知道外面还有谁在做出突然转向。这很有压力。
I get it. Having relied on the subway most of my life, driving scares the crap out of me too. But I needed Evan to get his head in the game. You see, by now I was starting to think that Chris and Evan might not immediately or ever become fast friends. They might just be too different.
我懂。大半辈子依赖地铁，开车也把我吓得够呛。但我需要埃文投入状态。你看，当时我开始认为克里斯和埃文可能不会立刻或者永远成为至交。他们可能太不同了。
But whether they recognized it or not, there was something that connected them. I could see it from my perch 1,800 miles away, even when they couldn't. Evan is a deep-dive pop culture junkie. Chris is an English professor who's into sports. They were opposite sides of an egg-headed coin. Between them, I figured they must have the gamut of trivia game minutiae thoroughly covered. If my experiment wouldn't generate a lifelong friendship, at least it was within my power to forge the mightiest trivia team in all of Austin on this particular Wednesday night. In this hope, I was not alone. Evan was poised to win.
但无论他们是否意识到，有些东西连接着他们。我从1800英里外就能看出这一点，即使他们自己看不出来。埃文是个流行文化深度迷，克里斯是个爱好体育的英语教授。他们是书呆子硬币的两面。我想他们合起来肯定能涵盖琐事游戏的方方面面。如果我的实验不能造就一生的友谊，至少我有能力在这个特定的周三晚上打造奥斯汀最强大的琐事竞赛队伍。在这一点上，我不孤单。埃文已经准备好获胜了。
If there's a whole bunch of superhero video game [BLEEP] out there, you better believe I want to [BLEEP] try and own it. Yeah.
“如果外面有一大堆超级英雄电子游戏……你最好相信我想尝试并搞定它。是的。”
Well, I know I looked at the website for the trivia night, and I saw some Star Wars references and things.
“嗯，我知道我看了琐事之夜的网站，看到了《星球大战》的参考文献之类的东西。”
Yeah, I saw Star Wars and Lord of the Rings and some other stuff. But you know, I've got my weaknesses in certain areas.
“是的，我看到了《星球大战》和《指环王》还有其他一些东西。但你知道，我在某些领域有弱点。”
Wait, what are your weaknesses? I don't know what your weaknesses are.
等等，你的弱点是什么？我不知道你的弱点是什么。
Tolkien? I don't [BLEEP] with Tolkien at all.
“托尔金？我根本不看托尔金的东西。”
Really?
“真的？”
Yeah, no. No, that [BLEEP] was always too white for me.
“是啊，不。不，那些东西对我来说太‘白人化’了。”
The night of the man date arrives, and I hear nothing from Chris or Evan. Not a text, not an email. The next morning, still nothing. I finally talked to Chris that afternoon about how the night went. Being the eager one, he'd gotten to the bar first.
男人约会的夜晚到了，我没收到克里斯或埃文的任何消息。没有短信，没有邮件。第二天早上，依然什么都没有。最终那天下午我跟克里斯谈了谈晚上过得怎么样。作为积极主动的那一方，他先到了酒吧。
I got there, and I was going table to table, asking if we could sit down. And every single person said no. It reminded me of elementary school, where you're going table to table asking if you can sit. All of the cool kids are saying no. I mean, that's kind of what it felt like. I really felt like I was already in the hole before Evan even arrived.
我到了那里，挨桌询问是否可以坐下。每个人都说了不。这让我想起了小学时，你挨桌问能否坐下，所有的酷小孩都拒绝你。我的意思是，感觉就像那样。在埃文到达之前，我就觉得我已经陷入了深坑。
They'd agreed ahead of time on how they would recognize each other.
他们事先约定好了如何认出对方。
He told me that he was going to be wearing a purple shirt and yellow shoes, and he was going to be limping slightly because he had a stubbed toe. So I got there a little bit early. I ordered a drink right away.
他告诉我要穿一件紫色的衬衫和黄色的鞋子，走路会微微一瘸一拐，因为脚趾碰伤了。我到得早了点。立刻点了一杯饮料。
Can I get a Fonrazade?
能给我杯饮料吗？
And I saw him stride up to the first white dude with a blue shirt sitting near the stage and just go introduce himself, and it wasn't me. And as soon as I saw it, I said, this is my guy.
我看见他大步走向舞台旁坐着的第一个穿蓝衬衫的白人，上前做自我介绍，那人不是我。我一看见，就说：这就是我要找的人。
How tight was his shirt? I know how Evan likes his shirts tight.
他的衬衫有多紧？我知道埃文喜欢那种紧身衬衫。
(CHUCKLING) It was a shirt I would not be able to wear out in public. And then he sat down, and then the first thing he did was order a lemonade. And I thought, oh no. This is going to be bad.
（笑）那是件我没法穿出门的衬衫。然后他坐下，做的第一件事是点了一杯柠檬水。我想：哦，不。这下糟糕了。
Evan eventually ordered some bourbon, but not too much. Moderation.
埃文最终点了一些波本威士忌，但没多喝。适度原则。
So I said, we need a team name. What do you want? And he just ripped off. He said, we're the Lonely Transplants. And I said, all right. And I thought that was a little on the nose. I mean, it was a little briefer than "Two dudes, one from New York, one from California, both of whom can't find any friends, blah, blah, blah." But yeah, Lonely Transplants was our name.
所以我说：“我们需要个队名。你想要什么？”他脱口而出：“我们是‘孤独的移植者’。”我说：“好吧。”我觉得这有点太直白了。我的意思是，比“两个家伙，一个来自纽约，一个来自加州，都找不到朋友”要简洁。但是的，“孤独的移植者”就是我们的名字。
The Lonely Transplants, Lonely Transplants.
“孤独的移植者，孤独的移植者。”
All right.
“好吧。”
Welcome to town. Enjoy the food.
“欢迎来到这个城市。尽情享受食物吧。”
The trivia night that Chris and Evan went to is officially called "Geeks Who Drink." And Evan killed it, just as I had hoped. Chris was impressed.
克里斯和埃文去的那个琐事之夜，官方叫“爱喝酒的书呆子”。埃文表现得极其出色，正如我所期望的。克里斯印象深刻。
There was a whole category about directors. They would show us clips, and we would have to guess what the movie was. And he was getting those left and right. And I honestly sat there. I sat there for entire rounds without doing anything.
有一个关于导演的类别。他们展示片段，我们要猜电影名。他接二连三地猜对了。我老实坐着。有好几轮我都没动一下。
The Lonely Transplants did not turn out to be the quick-fire, mind-melded dream team that I had hoped for.
“孤独的移植者”并没有成为我所期望的那种快速响应、心灵相通的梦之队。
There was one where the answer was a loofah, like a bath loofah. It's an organic substance that you have to microwave once a day so it cleans out the bacteria. And for whatever reason, I thought it was a sea cucumber. And he's like, no, it's a loofah. And I was like, no, I promise it's a sea cucumber. And if it's wrong, I will leave.
有一个问题答案是丝瓜络，那种洗澡用的。那是种有机物，每天都要微波加热一次来清理细菌。不管怎么着，我当时以为是海参。他说：“不，那是丝瓜络。”我说：“不，我保证那是海参。如果错了，我就走人。”
Chris says Evan didn't actually force him to leave or hold it over his head that he wasn't pulling his weight. Chris took that to mean that things were going well between them. The Lonely Transplants came in 19th out of about 30 teams.
克里斯说埃文并没有真的强迫他离开，也没有揪着他不放。克里斯认为这意味着他们之间进行得还不错。“孤独的移植者”在约30支队伍中排在第19位。
19th place, the Lonely Transplants.
“第19名，‘孤独的移植者’。”
But their meager showing didn't matter to Chris. This is a guy who had told me that he was missing spontaneity in his life, that his everyday felt scheduled around work and running errands and toddler parties. He was feeling like there were no surprises left. Suddenly, here he was trying to remember who recorded "Rock Me Amadeus" with this sort of awkward, sort of dapper black dude from Brooklyn.
但微薄的成绩对克里斯来说并不重要。他之前跟我说过，生活里缺乏自发性，每天感觉都被工作、跑腿和幼儿聚会填满了。他感觉没有惊喜了。突然间，他在这里试着和这个来自布鲁克林的有点尴尬、有点讲究的黑人小伙一起回想谁录制了《Rock Me Amadeus》。
And he knew it was by Falco. I had forgotten it was by Falco, and I didn't write down Falco. It was cool. Evan is a cool dude. And yeah, I think if there was an opportunity to meet someone like him out in the, quote-unquote, real world, I think I would have gone home, just floated on air, telling my wife about how excited I was for a potential new friend.
他知道是Falco唱的。我忘了是Falco，也没写下来。这很酷。埃文是个酷家伙。是的，我想如果能在所谓的现实世界里遇到像他这样的人，我会回家，飘飘然地告诉妻子我有多么兴奋遇到了一个潜在的新朋友。
But at the end of the night, the trivia host came over to talk to Chris and Evan. And something happened that left Chris feeling yet again a little inadequate.
但在晚上结束时，琐事之夜的主持人过来和克里斯与埃文聊天。发生了一件事，让克里斯再次感到一点自惭形秽。
Evan and the quizmasters went on this long riff about Star Wars and then Star Trek and the Death of Spock , and how that had a relation to men's feelings and loss. And I'm sure I saw those movies, but I was just nodding like an idiot. And it was at that moment where I thought, oh man. I got nothing.
埃文和测验主持人们就《星球大战》和《星际迷航》以及《史波克之死》聊了一长串，谈到这与男性的情感和失去有什么联系。我确信我看过那些电影，但当时我像个傻瓜一样点头。那一刻我想：哦，天哪。我什么都不懂。
Why would you need to microwave a sea cucumber to remove bacteria? That would just kill the sea cucumber. And what are you using a sea cucumber to wash anyway?
为什么要微波加热海参来去除细菌？那样会杀了海参。而且你洗澡用海参干什么？
After talking to Chris, naturally, I called Evan.
和克里斯谈过之后，我自然也联系了埃文。
How did it go?
进展如何？
Are we talking about the quiz part? Or are we talking about the making-a-friend part?
你是说测验部分？还是说交朋友的部分？
Just general impressions.
总的来说，印象如何？
Yeah, general impressions, I think it well. I definitely thought it was more fun than I was anticipating it to be. I can definitely see myself hanging out with him again.
是啊，总的来说，进展得不错。我绝对觉得比我预期的要有趣得多。我绝对可以看到自己以后还会和他一起玩。
This was confusing to me, because the entire time that I talked to Evan he just didn't say that much about Chris or how he himself felt about the date. If he had any impressions of Chris, he didn't let on. The only thing Evan got passionate about, and I should have expected this, was when I asked him to revisit the impromptu Star Trek conversation he had with the hosts at the end of the night.
这让我很困惑，因为整个谈话过程中，埃文并没有说太多关于克里斯的事，也没有说他自己对这次约会的真实感受。如果有任何印象，他没表现出来。埃文唯一热情的地方，我早该想到，是我请他回顾晚上结束时和主持人们关于《星际迷航》的即兴对话。
I love Wrath of Khan . And the friendship between Kirk and Spock has been a thing that I've always loved in science fiction pop culture. Kirk represented the brash, impulsive, seat of your pants mode of living that I never really pulled off. And Spock, he didn't fit in. And his emotions were not readily accessible to him. And his primary identifier was his intelligence, which is something I felt deeply.
我热爱《可汗怒吼》。Kirk和Spock之间的友谊是我在科幻流行文化中一直所珍视的。Kirk代表了一种我不曾拥有的张扬、冲动、随心所欲的生活模式。而Spock，他不属于那里。他的情绪对他来说不是唾手可得的。他最主要的身份认同是他的智力，这一点我感同身受。
Kirk and Spock were opposites thrown together under extreme circumstances and multiple alien encounters, who came to a level of mutual respect and admiration that spanned a galaxy and several franchise reboots. They were friends for decades who were willing to die for each other. By these standards, Chris and Evan's man date was not a rousing success.
Kirk和Spock是处在极端环境下被抛到一起的对立面，在多次外星遭遇中，达成了跨越星系和多次系列重启的相互尊重和钦佩。他们是几十年的朋友，愿意为彼此而死。用这些标准衡量，克里斯和埃文的男人约会并不是一次轰轰烈烈的成功。
But I'm more of a romantic comedy buff than a Star Trek fan. And rom-coms, for the most part, are only about the beginnings of relationships. By those standards, you just have to establish that first connection. All you really need are two people who both kind of want to meet someone and a powerful external force to bring them together, like a best friend's impending wedding or a forced road trip together or, say, a radio producer just trying to satisfy his own curiosity.
但我更多是个浪漫喜剧爱好者，而不是《星际迷航》粉丝。浪漫喜剧在很大程度上只关于关系的开端。按那个标准，你只需要建立那最初的联系。你所真正需要的，仅仅是两个都想要结识某人的人，再加上一股强大的外部力量将他们凑到一起，比如好朋友的婚礼、被迫的公路旅行，或者说，一个试图满足自己好奇心的电台制作人。
Would you like to hang out again?
你们想再出来玩吗？
Yeah. I would love to hang out with Evan again. I thought he was a really cool guy.
是的。我很乐意再和埃文一起玩。我觉得他是个很酷的家伙。
Would you consider calling Chris at some point or hanging out with him again?
你考虑在某个时间给克里斯打电话或再跟他见面吗？
Yeah. Yeah, totally. I was planning after I spoke to you-- I didn't want to muck up the process by emailing him prematurely. But yeah, I was planning to follow up and email him.
会。是的，完全会。我和你谈过之后就在计划了——我不想因为过早发邮件而弄乱了过程。但是的，我打算跟进并给他发邮件。
It's been three weeks since their date. Chris and Evan still haven't gotten together again. But Evan finally gave Chris his number, and they've been emailing back and forth about plans. I think it'll happen. Hell, I'd do it. Probably.
约会后已经过了三周了。克里斯和埃文还没再约过。但埃文终于给了克里斯号码，他们一直在邮件来往商量计划。我想这会发生的。见鬼，我也会这么做。大概吧。
Neil Drumming is one of the producers of our show.
尼尔·德鲁明是我们节目的制作人之一。
Coming up, you meet your hero. And maybe they're a jerk, maybe they're just OK, maybe they're wonderful. Why that third scenario might be the very, very worst. In a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，你遇见了你的偶像。也许他们是个混蛋，也许他们只是平平无奇，也许他们很棒。为什么第三种情况可能是最糟糕的，广告后继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme. Today's show, "The Perils of Intimacy," stories of what exactly can go wrong, big and small, when you get close to somebody. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three "Hero Today, Gone Tomorrow."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题。今天的节目是“亲密的代价”，讲述在与人亲近时可能出现的各种大小问题。我们来到了节目的第三幕，“英雄今日，明日不再”。
It can be so awkward meeting one of your heroes. I swear, there should be, like, a separate word for the phenomenon, for the specific problem of what in the world do you say or talk about that is going to live up to everything you know and feel about them. Kyle Mizono is a comedian, and she faced this problem herself with a man who, in this story, she just refers to as Hero.
遇见你的偶像有时会非常尴尬。我发誓，这种现象应该有一个单独的名词，来指代那种“该死，我到底该说些什么才能不辜负我对他所有的了解和感受”的特定问题。凯尔·米佐诺是一位喜剧演员，她本人就曾与一个在故事里被她称为“英雄”的人面对过这个问题。
One of the first jobs I got out of college was assisting on a video being made by a big hero of mine. My friend got me the job because she thought this would be a really fun thing for me to do. But I just thought, this is the worst thing ever, because I don't know if you can just tell by my energy, but I'm really bad at meeting most people. And this was meeting one of my heroes. And I've had so many awkward, horrible interactions that at a certain point, you just realize, maybe I shouldn't speak.
大学毕业后的第一份工作是为一个大偶像制作的视频担任助理。朋友给我介绍了这份工作，觉得这对我来说会很有趣。但我只觉得这是有史以来最糟的事，因为我不知道你们能否从我的能量感受到，我非常不擅长面对大多数人。而这次要见的是我的偶像。我经历过太多尴尬、糟糕的互动，以至于在某个时刻，你意识到：也许我不应该说话。
I took the job. But I had a plan. I was like, I'm going to ignore my hero. You know? He's not even going to know I'm there.
我接受了工作。但我有个计划，心想：我要无视我的偶像。他甚至不会注意到我的存在。
So I get there and immediately realize that this is a very small shoot. And there are only, like, seven people there. And one of the first people to introduce themselves to me was my hero. He was like, hi. I'm your hero. What's your name?
我到了那儿，立刻意识到这是个非常小的剧组。现场只有大约七个人。第一个向我自我介绍的人之一就是我的偶像。他说：“你好。我是你的偶像。你叫什么名字？”
And I just thought, this is the worst day ever! And it keeps happening, because he's this really nice guy. He'd pass by and he'd be like, are you having fun? How's it going? And I just wanted to say to him, like, why are you doing this to me?
我心想：这简直是有史以来最糟的一天！事情还在继续发生，因为他是个非常友善的家伙。他会走过来说：“玩得开心吗？一切都好吗？”我只想对他说：你为什么要对我做这种事？
But I made it through the day without speaking to him. They were so impressed with me. The producer was like, hey, we have another job. Why don't you drive your hero to and from another shoot. It's, like, an hour outside of LA.
但我一句话也没跟他说就熬过了那天。他们对我的表现印象深刻。制作人说：“嘿，我们还有另一份工作。你为什么不负责开车送你的偶像去另一个外景地？那在洛杉矶外一个小时车程的地方。”
And like, I couldn't say no. I wanted to say to this producer person, I can't handle this. I'm a danger to this man. But I said, OK. And now all these thoughts are going through my head. And I was like, there's just definitely going to be a moment where he shares something about himself, and I'm going to be like, I already know that. You know? Because I know everything about you.
我无法拒绝。我想对这个制作人说：我处理不了。对他来说我是个危险人物。但我说了“好的”。现在所有的想法都在脑海里打转。我想：肯定会有个时刻他会分享一些关于他自己的事，我会说：“我早就知道了。”你知道吗？因为我知道关于你的一切。
So we're in the car, and it's really hard to avoid someone who's in your car. But a strange thing happened. It was that I didn't feel as uncomfortable as I thought I'd feel, because he was just being so open and nice. I started sharing things. And I told him that he was one of the reasons why I had started doing comedy, and I was this aspiring comedian, and it was just so cool to work with him.
所以我们在车里，要避开坐在你车里的人真的很难。但一件奇怪的事情发生了。我并没有预想中那么不自在，因为他一直表现得那么开放和友善。我开始分享一些东西。我告诉他他是我开始做喜剧的原因之一，我是一个渴望成功的喜剧演员，能和他一起工作真是太酷了。
And as I was dropping him off, he said, I'd love to see you perform sometime. And he was probably being polite, but you've got to imagine being younger. It was just the most magical, exciting thing ever. And so a week later, I set about-- I went about composing just the perfect email to invite him to a show. And the great thing about email is that you don't have to send anything immediately. You can draft things. You can really take your time and make sure it's right.
当我要送他下车时，他说：“我很希望能看看你的表演。”他可能只是礼貌性说说，但你得想象一下那时的我有多年轻。那简直是有史以来最神奇、最令人兴奋的事情。所以一周后，我着手……我开始起草那封完美的邮件邀请他来看演出。邮件的好处是你不用立刻发送。你可以打草稿。你可以花时间确保一切无误。
And that's what I did. I made all these drafts. I made sure all the info was there about the event. And I made sure the grammar was right and the spacing. And I even made sure I sounded like a fun person, you know? Like, I sounded-- you read it, and you were like, that girl's fun.
我就是那么做的。我写了很多草稿。我确保所有活动的细节都在里面。我确保语法正确，间距适宜。我甚至确保听起来是个有趣的人，你知道吗？读起来就像：“那个女孩很有趣。”
And I never heard back. But it didn't even matter, because I was like, he's just busy. He's this busy guy. And also I just felt like I had made this really good impression.
但我从未收到回复。但这根本不重要，因为我想：他只是很忙。他是个大忙人。而且我觉得我给他留下了非常好的印象。
And that was five years ago. And I kept doing comedy. And I was on Gmail very recently. And something that I like to do-- so I was just nostalgically looking at old emails I had sent. It's just this weird thing I like to do, because occasionally I'll see a fun one and I'll forward it to a friend and be like, remember when I said that?
那是五年前的事了。我继续做着喜剧。最近我在Gmail里，我喜欢做的一件事……我带着怀旧心情看着我发过的旧邮件。这是我喜欢做的怪事，因为偶尔我会看到一封有趣的邮件，转发给朋友说：“记得我当时这么说吗？”
So I was doing that. And I scrolled way down. And I stumbled upon the very email that I had written to my hero five years ago. "Dear hero, set aside two tickets for you to next month's show on January 19, if you can make it. If not, it's every month, so there's always a next time. Also, the shoot turned out awesome." It's pretty good, right?
所以我正在做那个。我向下一路翻找。我偶然发现了五年前我写给偶像的那封信。“亲爱的英雄，如果你能来的话，请为下个月1月19日的演出留两张票。如果不能，演出每月都有，所以还有下次。另外，那次拍摄真的很棒。”挺不错的，对吧？
That was sent at 12:01. And then underneath that, I found another one sent at 12:01. It's within the same minute. "Dear hero, set aside two tickets for you to next month's show on January 19, if you can make it." And then I added, "Hope you had a wonderful holiday!"
那封是12:01发送的。在下面，我发现了另一封也是12:01发送的。在同一分钟内。“亲爱的英雄，请为下个月1月19日的演出留两张票，如果你能来的话。”然后我加了一句：“希望你有个愉快的假期！”
And then I found another one underneath that. Sent at 12:02. I had confused saving with sending, and my comedy hero received all of my drafts.
然后我在下面发现了另一封。12:04发送。我把保存和发送搞混了，我的喜剧英雄收到了我所有的草稿。
"Dear hero, set aside two tickets for you to next month's show on January 19, if you can make it." And there's this huge gap. And then I added, "Also, the shoot turned out awesome. Yeah!"
“亲爱的英雄，请为下个月1月19日的演出留两张票，如果你能来的话。”这里有个巨大的空格。然后我加了一句：“另外，拍摄真的很棒。耶！”
"Dear hero," and this one, at 12:04, just added the venue. It's 12:04 again. Now I just added the time. Now, it's 12:05, and I just added, parentheses, doors at 7:00 PM. You know, just in case he wants to come early when the doors open. 12:05, same email. 12:06, same email.
“亲爱的英雄”，这一封在12:04，只是加上了地点。又是12:04。现在我加上了时间。现在是12:05，我又加上了括号，“下午7:00入场”。你知道，万一他想在开门时早点来呢。12:05，同一封邮件。12:06，同一封邮件。
And then this big time gap happens. Now it's 12:21. And I say, "Dear hero, hol." It's just H-O-L, just a spelling error. And then at 12:25, I send it off. But of course in my style, I send it off twice.
然后时间出现了一个大缺口。现在是12:21。我说：“亲爱的英雄，h-o-l。”这只是个拼写错误。然后12:25，我发了出去。当然，按我的风格，我发了两次。
I can't believe I did that. And if I had known about this, I don't know if I would be standing here in front of you tonight. It would have been too embarrassing to do anything in comedy, ever, after doing this sort of thing to my comedy hero. And I also don't think I would be here tonight, because I would be in a nut house, just rocking back and forth, saying, "Also, the shoot turned out awesome! Also, the shoot turned out awesome! Also, the shoot turned out awesome!" Thank you. Thank you so much.
我不敢相信我竟然做了这种事。如果当时我知道这件事，我不知道今晚还会不会站在这里。做了这种事之后，再在喜剧界做任何事都太尴尬了。我也不觉得我会今晚在这里，因为我会被关进精神病院，坐在那里前后摇晃，嘴里念叨着：“拍摄真的很棒！拍摄真的很棒！拍摄真的很棒！”谢谢。非常感谢。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Kyle Mizono is a comedian in Los Angeles.
凯尔·米佐诺是洛杉矶的喜剧演员。
[MUSIC - "ANTI-LOVE SONG" BY BETTY DAVIS]
（音乐 - 贝蒂·戴维斯的《反情歌》）
Act Four, "Break It Down." So we end our show today about the perils of intimacy with this story that tries to tally up what is good and what is bad about getting close to somebody. This is one of my favorite short stories. It's by Lydia Davis. It's read first by actor Matt Malloy. Warning to listeners, this story does acknowledge that people have sex.
第四幕，“拆解它”。今天我们用这个故事结束关于亲密代价的节目，它试图盘点与人亲近的得与失。这是我最喜欢的短篇小说之一，作者是莉迪亚·戴维斯。首先由演员马特·马洛伊朗读。提醒听众，这个故事承认人们有性行为。
He's sitting there, staring at a piece of paper in front of him. He's trying to break it down. He says, I'm breaking it all down. The ticket was $600. And after that, there was more for the hotel and food and so on, for just 10 days. Say $80 a day. No, more like $100 a day.
他坐在那里，盯着面前的一张纸。他试图把一切拆解开。他说：“我正在把这一切拆开。票价是600美元。在那之后，还有酒店、食物之类的开销，仅仅10天。算一天80美元。不，更像是每天100美元。”
And we made love, say, once a day. On the average, that's $100 a shot. And each time, it lasted maybe two or three hours. So that would be anywhere from $33 to $50 an hour, which is expensive.
“我们做爱，算一天一次。平均下来，那是一次100美元。每一次大概持续两三个小时。所以那就是每小时33到50美元，挺贵的。”
Though, of course, that wasn't all that went on, because we were together almost all day long. So that means she would keep looking at me. And every time she looked at me, that was worth something. And she smiled at me and didn't stop talking and singing. Something I said, she would sail into it, a snatch, for me. She would be gone from me, a little ways, but smiling too. And tell me jokes. I loved it.
“当然，那不是发生的全部，因为我们几乎整天都在一起。这意味着她会一直看着我。每次她看着我，那都值得一些什么。她对我微笑，没完没了地说话、唱歌。我说点什么，她就会参与进来，一段插曲。她会偶尔离开我一会儿，但也在微笑。给我讲笑话。我爱死了。”
I didn't exactly know what to do about it. Just smiled back at her and felt slow next to her, just not quick enough. So she talked and touched me on the shoulder and the arm. She kept touching and stayed close to me. You're with each other all day long, and it keeps happening, the touches and smiles. And it adds up. It builds up. And you know where you'll be that night.
“我不知道该怎么办。只是回以微笑，在她身边感到迟钝，不够快。所以她说话，触碰我的肩膀和手臂。她一直触碰，一直待在我身边。你们整天在一起，那一直发生，触摸和微笑。它积累起来。它建立起来。你知道那天晚上你会去哪儿。”
You're talking, and every now and then you think about it. No, you don't think. You just feel it as kind of a destination, what's coming up after you leave wherever you are all evening. And you're happy about it. And you're planning it all. Not in your head, really. Somewhere inside your body, or all through your body, it's all mounting up and coming together so that when you get in bed, you can't help it. It's a real performance. It all pours out, but slowly.
“你在交谈，时不时会想到那个。不，你不是在想。你只是把它当作一种目的地去感觉，当你离开那个你们整晚待着的地方后，即将发生什么。你为之感到快乐。你在脑海里筹划一切。其实不是脑子里。在你的身体某处，或者贯穿全身，这一切都在汇聚、积累，当你上床时，你无法控制。这是一场真正的表演。一切都倾泻而出，但很缓慢。”
You go easy until you can't anymore. Or you hold back the whole time. You hold back and touch the edges of everything. You edge around until you have to plunge in and finish it off. And when you're finished, you're too weak to stand. But after a while, you have to go to the bathroom and you stand. Your legs are trembling. You hold on to the door frames. There's a little light coming in through the window. You can see your way in and out, but you can't really see the bed.
“你轻松前行直到无法再轻松为止。或者你全程克制。你克制着，触碰一切的边缘。你边缘徘徊直到必须潜入并完成它。当你完成时，你虚弱得无法站立。但过了一会儿，你得去洗手间，你站了起来。腿在颤抖。你扶着门框。窗外透进一点光。你能看清进出的路，但无法看清床。”
So it's really not a $100 a shot, because it goes on all day, from the start when you wake up and feel her body next to you. You don't miss a thing, not a thing of what's going on next to you-- her leg, her arm, her shoulder, her face, that good skin. I've felt other good skin, but this skin is just the edge of something else.
“所以那绝不是一次100美元，因为它持续了一整天，从你醒来感觉到她身体就在你身边开始。你什么都没错过，没有错过你身边发生的任何事情——她的腿、她的手臂、她的肩膀、她的脸，那美丽的肌肤。我感受过其他美妙的肌肤，但这肌肤是别的东西的边缘。”
And you're going to start going. I mean, no matter how much you crawl all over each other, it won't be enough. And when your hunger dies down a little bit, then you start to think about how much you love her. And then that starts you off again. And her face, and you look over to her face and you can't believe how you got there and how lucky. And it's all still a surprise, and it never stops. I mean, even after it's over, it never stops being a surprise.
“而你就要开始了。我的意思是，无论你们怎么在对方身上爬，都不够。当你的饥饿感稍稍平息，你就开始想你有多爱她。然后那又重新开启了一切。还有她的脸，你看着她的脸，你不敢相信你是怎么走到这一步的，多么幸运。这依然是一个惊喜，它永远不会停止。我是说，即使结束后，它也从未停止成为一个惊喜。”
It's more like you have a good 16 or 18 hours a day of this going on. Even when you're not with her, it's still going on. I mean, it's good to be away from her because it's going to be so good to get back to her. You know, it's still there in you. And you can't go off and look at some old street or some old painting without feeling it in your body and a few things that happened the day before that don't mean much by themselves, or wouldn't mean much if you weren't having this thing together, but you can't forget. And it's all inside of you all the time.
“更像是你每天有16到18个小时在经历这些。即使你没和她在一起，这也在持续。我是说，离开她也是好的，因为回到她身边会感觉更好。你知道，它依然在你体内。你无法走出房门去看看老街或画作，而不感到身体里的这种感觉，以及前一天发生的一些事——它们本身没什么意义，或者如果你没有这种体验就不会有什么意义，但你无法忘记。这一切一直都在你体内。”
So it's more like, say, 16 into 100 would be $6 an hour, which isn't too much. But it isn't over when it ends. I mean, it goes on after it's all over. She's still inside you, like a sweet liqueur. You're filled with her. Everything about her has kind of bled into you-- her voice, her smell, the way her body moves. It's all inside of you, at least for a while after.
“所以更像是，比如100除以16等于每小时6美元，这不算太贵。但它结束时并没有真的结束。我的意思是，即使一切结束后，它还在继续。她依然在你体内，就像一种甜美的利口酒。你被她充盈。关于她的一切都渗入了你——她的声音、她的气味、她身体移动的方式。这一切都在你体内，至少在结束后一段时间里。”
Then you begin to lose it. And I'm beginning to lose it. You're afraid of how weak you are, that you can't get her all back into you again, and now the whole thing is going to be out of your body, and it's more in your mind than in your body. And the pictures come to you, one by one, and you look at them. Some of them last longer than others. The pictures come to you, and you have to hope they won't lose their life too fast and dry up, though you know they will, and that you'll also forget some of what happened, because already you're turning up little things that you nearly forgot.
“然后你开始失去它。我开始失去它了。你害怕自己的虚弱，害怕你无法再把她带回体内，现在一切都将从你体内流出，它更多是在你脑海中而非体内。画面一个接一个地向你走来，你看着它们。有些画面持续得比其他更长久。画面向你走来，你必须希望它们不会失去生命太快而枯竭，尽管你知道它们会的，而且你也会忘记发生过的一些事情，因为你已经翻出了你几乎忘记的小事。”
We were in bed, and she asked me, do I seem fat to you? And I was surprised, because she didn't seem to worry about herself at all in that way. And I guess I was reading into it that she did worry about herself. So I answered what I was thinking and said stupidly that she had a very beautiful body, that her body was perfect. And I really meant it as an answer, but she said kind of sharply, that's not what I asked.
“我们在床上，她问我：‘我看起来胖吗？’我很惊讶，因为她在那方面似乎一点也不担心自己。我猜我解读出她在担心自己。所以我回答了我的想法，愚蠢地说她有非常美丽的身体，她的身体是完美的。我是真心这么回答的，但她有点尖锐地说：‘我问的不是这个。’”
And so I had to try to answer her again exactly what she had asked. And once she lay over against me late at night, and she started talking, her breath in my ear, and she just went on and on and talked faster and faster. She couldn't stop. And I loved it. I just felt that all that life in her was running into me too. I had so little life in me. Her life, her fire was coming into me in that hot breath in my ear. And I just wanted her to go on talking forever right there next to me.
“于是我得尝试再次回答她确切的问题。有一次，深夜她躺在我身边，她开始说话，呼吸声在我耳边，她喋喋不休，语速越来越快。她停不下来。我爱死那个了。我感觉她身上所有的生命力都在流向我。我体内生命力太少了。她的生命力、她的火焰正通过耳边那灼热的呼吸进入我的体内。我只想让她就在我身边永远说下去。”
And I would go on living like that. I would be able to go on living but without her. I don't know. Then you forget some of it all, maybe most of it all, almost all of it in the end. And you work hard at remembering everything now so you won't ever forget. But you can kill it too, even by thinking about it too much, though you can't help but thinking about it nearly all the time.
“我本来可以那样继续生活。我应该能继续生活下去，只是没有她。我不知道。然后你忘记了其中一些，也许大部分，最终几乎全部。你现在努力记住一切，这样你就永远不会忘记。但你也会扼杀它，甚至仅仅因为想得太多，尽管你几乎无时无刻不在想它。”
And then when the pictures start to go, you start asking some questions, just little questions that sit in your mind without any answers, like, why did she leave the light on when you came to bed one night, but it was off the next? But she had it on the night after that, and she had it off the last night. Why? And other questions, little questions that nag at you like that.
“然后当画面开始消失，你开始提出一些问题，只是坐在你脑海中没有任何答案的小问题，比如，为什么你有一天上床时她留着灯，而第二天却关了？但后一天她又开着，最后一天又关了。为什么？还有其他问题，像这样纠缠你的小问题。”
And finally the pictures go, and these dry little questions just sit there without any answers, and you're left with this large heavy pain in you that you try to numb by reading. Or you try to ease it by getting out into public places where there'll be people around you. But no matter how good you are at pushing that pain away, just when you think you're going to be all right for a little while, that you're safe, you're kind of holding it off with all your strength and you're staying in some bare little numb spot of ground, then suddenly it will all come back. You'll hear a noise. Maybe it's a cat crying or a baby, something else like her cry.
“最后画面消失了，这些干瘪的小问题就那样存在着，没有任何答案，你只剩下这种充满全身的沉重痛苦，你试着通过阅读来麻木它。或者通过去人们环绕的公共场所来缓解它。但无论你多么擅长推开那种痛苦，就在你以为你会好一阵子，你是安全的时候，你用尽全身力气阻挡它，待在某块光秃秃的小泥地上，然后突然它又回来了。你会听到一种声音。也许是一只猫的叫声或是一个婴儿的哭声，某些像她哭声一样的东西。”
You hear it and make that connection in a part of you you have no control over, and that pain comes back so hard that you're afraid, afraid of how you're going to fall back into it again. And you wonder-- no, you're terrified-- at how you're ever going to climb out of it.
“你听到它并在你无法控制的部分建立了那种联系，那种痛苦如此猛烈地回来，让你感到害怕，害怕你将如何再次坠入其中。你惊奇地发现——不，你是恐惧——你将如何从中爬出来。”
So it's not every hour of the day while it's happening. It's really for hours and hours every day after that, for weeks, though less and less, so that you could work out a ratio if you wanted. Maybe after six weeks, you're only thinking about it an hour or so in the day altogether, a few minutes here and there, spread over-- or a few minutes here and there, and a half an hour before you go to sleep. Or sometimes it all comes back and you stay awake half the night. So when you add up all that, you've only spent maybe $3 an hour on it.
“所以不是事情发生时一天的每一小时。其实是之后每天几个小时几个小时，持续数周，尽管越来越少，如果你想的话可以算出个比率。也许六周后，你一天总共只想它一个小时左右，零零星星几分钟，或者在你入睡前半小时。或者有时一切又回来了，你整晚辗转难眠。所以当你加上所有这些，你可能只在那上面花了每小时3美元。”
If you have to figure in the bad times too, I don't know. There weren't any bad times with her, though. Maybe there was one bad time, when I told her I loved her. I couldn't help it. This was the first time this had happened with her. Now I was half falling in love with her, or maybe completely if she'd let me. But she couldn't, or I couldn't completely, because it was all going to be so short and other things too.
“如果你也得计入糟糕的时候，我不知道。虽然和她在一起时没有糟糕的时候。也许有过一次糟糕的时刻，当我告诉她我爱她的时候。我忍不住。这是第一次与她发生这种情况。现在我已经有一半坠入爱河了，如果她允许的话，甚至可能全部坠入爱河。但她不能，或者我也不能完全坠入爱河，因为它注定会很短暂，还有其他原因。”
And so I told her. And I didn't know of any way to tell her first that she didn't have to feel that this was a burden, the fact that I loved her, or that she didn't have to feel the same about me or say the same back, that it was just that I had to tell her, that's all, because it was bursting inside me. And saying it wouldn't even begin to take care of what I was feeling, really. I couldn't say anything of what I was feeling because there was so much words couldn't handle it.
“所以我告诉了她。我不知道有什么方法能先告诉她，让她觉得这不是个负担——我爱她这件事——或者她不必对我有同样的感觉或回报同样的词句，我只是必须告诉她，仅此而已，因为它在我心中胀开了。说出来甚至不能开始处理我的感受，真的。我无法说出我的感受，因为有太多话语无法处理的事情。”
And making love only made it worse, because then I wanted words badly but they were no good, no good at all. But I told her anyway. I was lying on top of her. And her hands were up by her head, and my hands were on hers. And our fingers were locked, and there was a little light on her face from the window, but I couldn't see her. And I was afraid to say it, but I had to say it because I wanted her to know.
“而做爱只会让事情变得更糟，因为那时我非常渴望言语，但它们没有用，一点用都没有。但我还是告诉了她。我躺在她身上。她的双手在头边，我的手扣着她的。我们的手指锁在一起，窗户照进一点光在她的脸上，但我看不清她。我害怕说出来，但我必须说，因为我想让她知道。”
It was the last night. I had to tell her then, or I'd never have another chance. And I just said, before you go to sleep-- I have to tell you before you go to sleep that I love you. And immediately, right away after, she said, I love you too. And it sounded to me as if she didn't mean it, a little flat. But then it usually sounds flat when somebody says "I love you too," because they're just saying it back, even if they do mean it.
“那是最后一晚。我必须在那时告诉她，否则我永远没有机会了。我只是说：‘在睡着之前——在睡着之前我必须告诉你，我爱你。’立刻，就在之后，她说：‘我也爱你。’这听起来就像她并不是真心的，有点平淡。但当有人回说‘我也爱你’时通常听起来都很平淡，因为他们只是在回敬，即使他们是真心的。”
And the problem is that I'll never know if she meant it. Or maybe someday she'll tell me whether she meant it or not, but there's no way to know now. And I'm sorry I did that. It was a trap I didn't mean to put her in. I can see it was a trap, because if she hadn't said anything at all, that would have hurt me too, as though she were taking something from me and just accepting it and not giving anything back. So she really had to. I mean, even if just to be kind, she had to say it. And I don't really know now if she meant it.
“问题是，我永远不会知道她是否真心。或者也许有一天她会告诉我她是否真心，但现在没有办法知道。我很抱歉我那样做了。那是我不想让她陷入的陷阱。我看得出那是陷阱，因为如果她什么都不说，那也会伤害我，好像她在从我这里拿走什么，只是接受了却没有给予任何回应。所以她真的不得不说。我的意思是，即使只是为了仁慈，她也不得不说。我现在真的不知道她是否真心。”
Another bad time-- or it wasn't exactly bad, but it wasn't easy either-- was when I had to leave. The time was coming, and I was beginning to tremble and feel empty. Nothing in the middle of me, nothing inside, nothing to hold me up on my legs. And then it came. Everything was ready, and I had to go. So it was just a kiss, a quick one, as though we were afraid of what might happen after a kiss.
“另一个糟糕的时刻——或者说那并不完全糟糕，但也并不轻松——是我必须离开的时候。时刻即将来临，我开始颤抖，感到空虚。我内心中心什么都没有，什么都没有，没有东西支撑我的双腿。然后它来了。一切就绪，我必须走了。所以只是一个吻，一个仓促的吻，好像我们在害怕吻之后会发生什么。”
And she was almost wild then. She reached up to a hook by the door and took an old shirt, a green and blue shirt from the hook, and put it in my arms for me to take away. The soft cloth was full of her smell. And then we stood there, close together, looking at this piece of paper she had in her hand. And I didn't lose any of it.
“那时她几乎狂野。她伸手够向门边的钩子，拿下一件旧衬衫，一件蓝绿色的衬衫，递到我的怀里让我带走。柔软的布料充满她的气味。然后我们站在那里，靠近在一起，看着她手中那张纸。我没错过任何细节。”
I was holding it tight, that last minute or two, because this was it. We'd come to the end of it. Things always change, so this was really it. Over.
“我把它抓得很紧，那最后的一两分钟，因为这就是结局了。我们到了尽头。事物总是在变，所以这就是结局了。结束了。”
Maybe it works out all right. Maybe you haven't lost for doing it. I don't know. No, really. I mean, sometimes, when you think of it, you feel like a prince, really. You feel just like a king. And other times, you're afraid. You're afraid, not all the time, but now and then, of what it's going to do to you. And it's hard to know what to do with it now.
“也许一切都会好起来。也许你没因为做这件事而输掉。我不知道。不，真的。我的意思是，有时，当你想到它，你感觉自己像个王子，真的。你感觉就像个国王。而另一些时候，你感到害怕。你感到害怕，不是一直，但时不时地害怕它会对你做什么。现在你很难知道该怎么处理它。”
Walking away, I looked back once, and the door was still open. I could see her standing far back in the dark in the room. I could only really see her white face, still looking out at me, and her white arms.
“走开的时候，我回头看了一眼，门还开着。我能看见她站在房间深处的黑暗中。我真的只能看见她白皙的脸，还在看着我，还有她白皙的手臂。”
I guess you get to a point where you look at that pain as if it were there in front of you three feet away, lying in a box, an open box in a window somewhere. It's hard and cold, like a bar of metal. You just look at it there and say, all right. I'll take it. I'll buy it.
“我想你到了某个点，看着那痛苦，好像它就在你三英尺远的地方，躺在一个盒子里，一个窗户里的打开的盒子里。它又硬又冷，像根金属条。你只是看着它在那儿说：‘好吧。我接受。我会买单。’”
That's what it is, because you know all about it before you even go into this thing. You know the pain is part of the whole thing. And it isn't that we can say afterwards the pleasure was greater than the pain and that's why you'd do it again. That has nothing to do with it. You can't measure it, because the pain comes after and it lasts longer. So the question really is, why doesn't the pain make you say I won't do it again? When the pain is so bad that you have to say that, but you don't?
“事情就是这样，因为在进入这桩事之前你就全知道了。你知道痛苦是整个事情的一部分。这不是说我们事后能说快乐大于痛苦，所以你才会再做一次。那与此无关。你无法衡量，因为痛苦在之后，而且持续时间更长。所以真正的问题是，为什么痛苦没有让你说‘我不会再做了’？当你痛苦到必须那样说的时候，却没有说？”
So I'm just thinking about it, how you can go in with $600, more like $1,000, and how you can come out with an old shirt.
“所以我只是在思考，你是如何带着600美元，更像是1000美元进入，而最后只带着一件旧衬衫出来。”
Matt Malloy, reading Lydia Davis's story, "Break It Down." It was first published in her book of the same name. It's also in her collected stories. We edited it slightly for radio.
马特·马洛伊朗读了莉迪亚·戴维斯的短篇《拆解它》。它首次发表在同名书集中。也收录在她的故事全集里。我们为广播进行了微调。
[MUSIC - "LADY, YOU SHOT ME" BY HAR MAR SUPERSTAR]
（音乐 - 哈·马尔超级明星的《女士，你射杀了我》）
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with help from Nancy Updike and our production staff, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lyra Smith, and Matt Tierney. Our editor is Joe Lovell. Editorial help Julie Snyder and Elna Baker. Research help from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩制作，南希·厄普代克及我们的制作团队佐伊·切斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德鲁明、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦、莱拉·史密斯和马特·蒂尔尼提供协助。我们的编辑是乔·洛弗尔。编辑协助朱莉·斯奈德和埃尔纳·贝克。研究协助克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉和米歇尔·哈里斯。音乐协助达米安·格拉夫和罗伯·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
And our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I tried talked to him about whether Daenarys Targaryen is going to end up on the Iron Throne with John Snow, and I just think he misunderstood.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我试着跟他谈论丹妮莉丝·坦格利安是否会和琼恩·雪诺一起坐在铁王座上，我觉得他理解错了。
Tolkien? I don't [BLEEP] with Tolkien at all. Yeah, no. No, that [BLEEP] was always too white for me.
“托尔金？我根本不看托尔金的东西。是啊，不。不，那些东西对我来说太‘白人化’了。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。